Dennis Quaid is here Dennis Quaid is
here Dennis Quaid is here all right now
can you guys see that we might look a
little bit alike huh No damn we try to
tell you things out of here
that guys in your stratosphere with hair
yeah Dennis got good hair can you see no
you can't see a resemblance here but I
have people who say you know you look a
little bit like Dennis Quaid I can see
it thank you
me too are you acting right now Dennis
you're acting right now aren't you you
mean at this very minute yes you are
Dennis is playing opposite Kate Bosworth
here's your full full intro here the
show is called the art of more now in
its second season check it out on Sony's
crackle also uh Jerry Seinfeld show yes
it's on there as well as sports on there
as well so you're playing up night and I
know you get this but it feels like
there's a Donald Trump type field to
your characters that's the way it worked
out you know the the first season we had
already written all of the scripts we
were two months into shooting and you
know Donald Trump announces he's running
for president and I'm looking and I see
his my dialogue coming out of his mouth
and I don't know did it just write
itself because you just took a little
bit I mean the character is not based on
him but he is like a billionaire new
york tycoon real estate developer who
has a pension for politics know this
that's where it ends a crime drama set
in the high-stakes world of New York's
fine art world will continue to explore
the lines between ambition and greed
revenge and crime yeah
does anybody die in this yeah a few
people yeah yeah not me I have a gun
yeah that's how you know you're off the
show so you play Sam Bruckner you're the
real estate tycoon right with political
aspirations here although both out in
their seasons yes I did have that I was
running for governor and that didn't
work out too well but now it's
kind of the second season it's a kinder
gentler Sam Ragnar what do people say to
you on the street let's say in New York
well what do they ask what do they ask
you if I'm Kevin Costner or not that's
not bad they're convinced that's not bad
usually Innerspace they usually see me
they grew up with me yeah a lot of
people did so I had my Parent Trap girls
that I had me I had my rookie guy yes
and breaking away when the Breaking Away
cat again according to which decade it
was that you grew up in favorite sports
movie you were in
I would have saved the rookie but you um
and we were wondering about this do you
have to know sports or can you be can
you be taught to be or act as an athlete
well like in the rookie I I hadn't
thrown a pitch since Little League but I
got I I got to train for six months
before it and thank God I was a
left-hander like Jimmy Morris and I
never put myself on a radar gun he could
throw a hundred miles an hour yeah and
that helped all I wanted to do was just
get the motion right and and you did
yeah that's it's all I needed because I
think when it comes to baseball I'm
really I can't throw a cat out of a
house John John Goodman is great an
accuracy is didn't look like Babe Ruth
yeah but a pitching motion yeah but
that's what we look for when it comes to
any kind of sports movie mm-hmm
what other movie you play quarterback in
any given Sunday yeah yes how did you
adjust Oliver Stone last week down in
Mexico and I thought that was like
probably the best football movie I've
ever seen as far as being on the field
and what it's like to feel that violence
dealing with Pacino I mean he added
quite a few folks there yeah great
Fritzie do do your own Pacino
impersonation for Dennis look but don't
touch
so taste taste but don't swallow and
you're bouncing back and forth but he's
giggling it's a movie but it doesn't
matter that I was wrong I was inspired
by touchdown we could do it as guys
that's how he got a hernia
he's got hernia surgery coming up coming
up tomorrow fantastic first paid job was
what first in acting in acting I was uh
Jonathan Jimmy I was an extra in his
movie called crazy mama and I was a
bellhop and I said oh my god don't shoot
me to Donny most from happy Pappy did
yeah were you in stripes
no I was not my you're not an immersed
wife PJ soles was in stripes
see now you're listed as an extra on
your IMDB in stripes
yeah Wow but you're not no I'm not maybe
I should get residuals for them I don't
think it'd be pennies I think if you're
getting residuals but if you look at is
there a sports movie that hasn't been
told yet mmm because the Cubs just
winning the World Series that's the last
great sports story but I don't know
incredible but you may have to wait a
while yeah to reshoot that I know Golf
is the toughest sport to make a movie up
what did you think a tin cup
tin cup I thought was was was good I
thought I did think it was good but to a
general audience it's you know how does
if you're out to dinner and you get into
a golf conversation it's you feel
everybody sort of like turn off around
you excitement but do you and Costner
compete did you compete for roles
because it feels like we did age-wise
yes yeah yeah we were we were right
there
but is there competitiveness or how does
that work maybe a little bit that's
unspoken but you know it's it's good
it's good for both of us could you take
him if you had to
it depends on the venue octagon if I put
you in the Octagon Mme you against okay
now we're going because I would like to
have seen you pitch to Koster cuz he was
in Hitler he's a fantastic pitcher he's
a great baseball oh yeah excellent and
Bull Durham was a good movie - yeah very
very that was a lot of fun the movie you
wish you were you would have taken you
would have been in aa see oh wow
there was a bunch of them of the big it
was offered big oh you were yeah the Tom
Hanks well yeah but I was I was doing
another film at the time it's been
playing at Francis Ford Coppola offered
me Peggy Sue got married which was Cage
did that I was doing the Big Easy
instead he's mad yeah that Ellen Barkin
yes yeah
this was Ellen Barkin look great in the
biggies Oh Ellen Barkin was great
Pauling yes your question here for for
Dennis quite um when you were in Wyatt
Earp how tough is it to lose that much
weight for a role and to look sickly for
the role of Doc Holliday well looking
sickly is no problem dude it's hard to
look tuberculosis there I went for yes
he did I went from a hundred and eighty
two pounds down to 138 and I did it by
having a thousand calories a day and
then on the Stairmaster doing like 400
calories of a cardio and you know so I
had a net of six it was basically a powa
diet which got me down there and very
interesting it really changes your whole
way of thinking and I had to stay there
for like four months while be shot so if
if you could be nominated for an Academy
Award or Texas Longhorns win the
national championship well I've already
had the Texas Longhorns women have
another Winship
hey I gotta be selfish okay that's the
right answer by the way you know you
want to do one for the team
yeah yeah fritzy I would have been very
disappointed in Dennis if he picked
another Longhorns title over an Academy
Award you gotta grab the Academy Award
yes yeah Jenna they got to inspire first
don't you think
now do you what do you think is gonna
happen with this show like the arc when
they give you a show and say we're gonna
start here and then we're gonna go where
do you know where you're you're headed
here in second season or third yes
third season don't quite know where
we're going to be headed hopefully there
is a third season but what's great about
the art of Moore as is that the entire
script and about the Bible of where
you're going is there before you start
shooting so you have an arc of a
character which makes it so much better
to play rather than a procedural you can
see the show it's the art of more now in
its second season with Dennis opposite
Kate Bosworth and check it out starting
tomorrow on Sony's crackle yeah and it's
free crackle is free yes it is is google
it you go there and you're watching on
any device you Stannis Quig thank you
for stopping by Dennis thank you Dan we
looked so much alike
not so much alike the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience